[Music]
esports is a
truly global phenomenon but that doesn't
mean that
every region is on equal footing south
korea
china europe and yes even north america
have become competitive across many
games
well some more than others another
page in the tsm chapter of
disappointment but among the regions
that are expected to soak up all the
silverware are those that are fighting
just to be recognized
formidable dark horses that have
overcome incredible odds in spite of the
challenges they've faced along the way
he's in rage again he's defeated
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Applause]
the impossible two-time major winners
you are gone
the filipinos have eliminated rg
tnz have done it but breaking into the
top tier in
any esport is never easy for a
developing region
and even some of the world's most
prestigious scenes
have had their reputations dragged
through the mud by players
looking for shortcuts to the top but in
the world of
indian counter-strike there is one event
so
infamous that it didn't just send
shockwaves through the scene
it killed it a despicable
heinous act that would not only create
the region's greatest villain
but one of cs goes most notorious memes
so how did optic gaming's indian long
shot end in disgrace
and what the hell does microsoft word
have to do with any of this
i think he got the punishment he
deserves from social media itself
i think being shunned and remembered as
the person who
destroyed indian counter-strike esports
it'll carry on
regardless of where he goes
[Music]
okay so first things first optic gaming
announced the formation of the optic
india roster in june of 2018 and for the
counter-strike community there it seemed
like a big
opportunity to show what the country
could do
optic india is a new beginning
cracking india as a region would be huge
for both
optic and counter-strike the country has
over
four times as many people as the united
states living in an
area one third the size you're talking
about
perhaps one of the biggest potential
untapped market untapped market in
esports
why not get in right now when no one's
there right want to grow the brand
sure esports isn't that big right now
but if you're going to be the first
mover you get the community on your side
so how did they decide who to pick up
well the team didn't just appear out of
nowhere
the org actually held tryouts and they
claimed to have had
over a thousand applicants yeah so i
remember it right uh i had like a long
uh like written process where people had
to just write down stuff and it was easy
to like
filter out a lot of people based on that
and then of course a lot of people came
for the land tryout so it's kind of like
mixing people up taking notes the roster
that emerged from the process was
composed of
marzil antidote haivan
formless and nikhil forsaken kumawat
a lurking support player who was
introduced by optic as someone trying to
redeem his image
he was like the persona non-grata of the
scene he rose to fame and success very
quickly from being a nobody to somebody
who is
quite literally dominating most of the
pro guys in the sea
that tarnished image was because most
members of the indian cs community were
aware that forsaken had had previous
run-ins with scandal in 2017. i remember
he got banned temporarily by isik
when he had confessed to or rather he
was caught
selling steam accounts of which one of
the accounts got back fan if i'm not
mistaken which he had owned in the past
he claimed that he sold the account but
according to esic rules it doesn't
matter if you sold the account or not
because you're not supposed to actually
sell an account it's not legal per se
but the ban still held
and after that he wrote multiple emails
or he claimed to have multiple emails
and
he got the band revoked to six months
regardless of whether forsaken story was
true
he'd done well enough during trials to
earn a spot on the roster
and in july optic rounded out their
lineup by bringing in
german import yb as the team's in-game
leader
buoyed by his acquisition the team set
their sights on qualifying for some big
lan events to prove that they could hang
with asia's best
and eventually they did just that
earning a spot at extremes land
zowie asia cs go 2018 as their region's
only representative
so we were just trying to make sure we
do our best in the event so that
they have some reason to retain our
roster to keep supporting it regardless
of
what happens uh at least make it to the
quarterfinals semifinals and everything
optic india had a dreamt of making
history
and they did just unfortunately
not in a way that anyone predicted
during optic india's group stage match
against revolution
marzil who was sitting next to forsaken
tried to call a pause for a technical
issue with his monitor
so then i see an admin coming behind my
pc rent because
my pc is next to his pc and i'm like no
no it's okay it's all good uh i
have my issue resolved and then that was
like no no wait anyone goes to
forsaken's pc right
and he minimizes the game now as it
happens the admins had already
discovered something out of place on
forsaken's ssd
so they took the opportunity to check
the folder
so he goes to that folder and then he
opens that file and i distinctly
remember around
three words which was have fun and
hack or something on those lines right
and i'm like what the hell
and that's when it that's the part of
the video where you see i'm looking
like days like what is going on forsaken
tried to bat away the admin
and delete the files but was asked to
step aside
that's when reality came crashing down
on not only marzil
but the rest of optic india and i'm just
like perplexed i'm like wait
what is this actually happening i i felt
i felt my hands go numb i was like
is this actually happening am i in a
dream what is this going on
and i i had like a series of emotions
run through me
i didn't know whether i should be angry
upset
sad i i had no control
things moved quickly after that the team
was disqualified and
optics sent forsaken home immediately
but the rest of the team had to wait for
their return flights in a few days
little did they know outside the walls
of their hotel the clip had gone
viral and the world of counter-strike
was reacting to what had happened
no i wasn't working that event i was i
was at home i woke up and my
my my phone my my alarm didn't drink
because my phone had hung
because too many messages and
notifications
it just blew up like my twitter my my
whatsapp like
everyone's like dude what the hell is
going on right and a key detail that
fans picked up on was the name that
forsaken had seemingly given his cheats
word.exe and similar to how vac became a
popular meme in the aftermath of the
2014 bands
word.exe became the standing term
for describing someone's hacks
it's become such a prevalent meme that
if you search
word.exe right now nearly everything
that pops up first
is actually related to forsaken and not
microsoft word
when you look at the overall scope of
things yes that kind of blew up right
it became a very memeable thing
everyone's talking about it honestly for
me i wasn't too
uh perturbed with that fact i was like
yeah it's going to be funny for a while
people are going to be talking a bit
about it but it's not a bad thing
overall it's not going to lead to
the death of the scene in the aftermath
reporting from
vp esports pointed to multiple
complaints from teammates
that something may have been awry with
forsaken's aim
but in the end it was the admins that
exposed him
and having been slammed with a five-year
ban by the esic
after it was revealed that he had used
an aimbot to cheat at previous
tournaments
forsaken pretty much disappeared from
the face of the earth
he ruined a lot of things for a lot of
people
but there's no way any of that is coming
back so there's no point in yelling at
him i think he got the punishment he
deserves from social media itself
i think being shunned and remembered as
the person who destroyed
indian counter-strike esports it'll
carry on regardless of where he goes
and as fans combed through forsaken
clips in october of 2018
one thing became pretty clear in
hindsight
there were some very obvious clips
like hilariously obvious
forsaken and antidote i'm gonna have to
try and retake the site luckily there is
a hole in the smoke so joseph's gonna
get some nice positioning
on the side and he's gonna be able to
get rid of
fog to the 2v2
nicely done
but while the world was joking around
the rest of
optic india were facing a hard reality
one in which they were unemployed and no
longer had the support of their org
we thought that optic would come out in
support of us and then
let us know that they got our backs and
you know at least
until the trip was over until we got
back home to indian soil
but all they said was we're shutting
down this division goodbye and
there was no funding support also from
that point was cut there was no money
coming in to actually feed us food when
we were in china for
lunch and dinner were still was the
potential fallout
optic were pretty much the biggest org
to ever have taken a chance on the
region
and now they'd withdrawn in disgrace
when we
went and and and scouted in india
for and obviously it turned out a [ __ ]
show because of that cheater
forsaken the world [ __ ] loser um
put to put on that brand and to [ __ ]
do that like he is lucky
like that i wasn't [ __ ] there because
i know that we're we're in indian rules
are different there
same thing if we were in mexico i'd
approach them a different way in a
situation like that
right but in spite of the shame that the
scandal had brought upon the former
members of optic india
it didn't sour their love for
counter-strike marzel and his teammates
went on to compete as part of
signify against south african squad
bravado at dreamhack invitational mumbai
a couple of months later where they beat
them in a 2-0
upset in the bracket and lost a narrow
2-1
grand final set proving once and for all
that they didn't need forsaken's hacks
to put up a fight
maybe the forsaken situation means that
counter-strike
won't be india's breakout esports
opportunity
even if it does have a scene that
players like marzil
hang onto tenaciously but even still
with the country's big population
increasingly interested in gaming and
esports it seems like keeping india off
the stage forever
is unlikely even if a scoundrel did
write part of its story
in word.exe it's an incident that
happened left behind a lot of memes
which honestly one life sounded pretty
funny even at that time
but it is what it is it wasn't really
gonna
leave a long-term effect on the scene
overall
even if a scoundrel did write part of
its story
in word.exe i just got it
like i just got the last line really
yeah
that's why i was trying to change it
yesterday because i was like it's so
good i just didn't get it it's my bad i
don't know what
maybe i was just tired yesterday or like
i don't know what the [ __ ] it was
it's so good no no it's so good josh
killed it i don't know whether
i didn't yeah i just i i think yesterday
was just a weird day like it was so
dreary and i was tired and i was just
like not
in it